or Russia's forces continued to threaten
Ukraine's Capital Kiev and for more on
that we're joined by our defense analyst
Michael Clark Michael let's have a look
at our first map shall we this is Kiev
what is going on at the moment yes
minkier has suffered some uh what looked
like rocket attacks which are extremely
destructive but the the nature of the
battle here is really revolving around
some of the fierce fighting that's going
on at places like Urban in the obelon
district and on the other side a place
like brovery and the reason that these
places are important for the battle for
Kiev is the distance they are from the
city center because if the Russians get
inside that area then they are within 15
or 18 miles of the city center and then
they can bring their Battlefield
artillery to play the howitzers which
would make quite a difference and what
sort of weapons are there what kind of
damage can they do yeah well howitzers
are they look like tanks they're based
on the Chang chassis but they've got a
pretty big gun on them so the guns are
uh 152 millimeter caliber guns they're
pretty Fierce they can fire six or eight
rounds of minute old-fashioned stuff old
Cold War stuff they're not all that
accurate but they certainly work and if
they can bring in their howitzers and
Surround two or three parts of the city
with them then they can threaten
threaten to reduce the city from the
outside in in a matter of a week or two
weeks whatever it is let's take a look
at the bigger picture shall we and talk
about the air War
what at the moment are the basic
dynamics of that well the the nature of
the air war is that both sides have got
quite a lot of aircraft in theater they
find it quite difficult to engage
together because the Russians have got
to come from bases inside Russia the
ukrainians have got to fly from Western
Ukraine which is quite long-rangement
for them and all of their aircraft are
dispersed in Western Ukraine so it we
expected the Russians to clear out the
Ukrainian air system from the very
beginning we thought they do it within
48 hours but actually the ukrainians are
still flying it looks as if they've got
about 50 odd aircraft or the 120 they
started with still in the air which is
pretty astonishing oh why hasn't Russia
with its Superior numbers started to
dominate the airspace well there's
probably a lot of reasons for that there
seems to be one is that Russian Pilots
only do about a hundred hours in the
cockpit flying every year NATO Pilots do
at least 200 hours the Russians don't
seem to work on combined uh air
operations so they don't do the complex
air operations that you need to do if
you're going to suppress enemy air
defenses and control the air again NATO
Pilots do that all the time all other
exercises are combined air operations
and so the Russians are flying you know
good aircraft actually very top of the
range aircraft but they're flying them
only in ones and twos they're flying at
night they're flying low because they
fear air defenses and they seem to fear
some of the aircraft which the
ukrainians have still got in the air so
there's a lot of reasons but I have to
say military analysts are still
scratching their heads as to why have
the Russians not made more of their
natural air superiority but they haven't
there's also been as we understand yet
some successful operations by the
Ukrainian forces on the ground yeah the
Ukrainian Marines it was a classic
attack they they attacked the air base
the air base under in in Russian hands
just outside michalev and they destroyed
at least 30 helicopters that's confirmed
and some more vehicles and they seem to
have got away it was a classic piece of
Commando work and then yesterday they
created an attack on the air base near
kirschen and it's not clear yet whether
it was artillery or it was air attacked
by the ukrainians but they just
destroyed I get about another 15
helicopters in a lot of vehicles it
seems that the the Russians are not
protecting their Forward Air bases very
well they're leaving their helicopters
in a line they're leaving stuff out and
the ukrainians are taking the
opportunities to actually uh get hold of
a lot of of air assets as we call them
on the ground so they're destroying a
lot of stuff while it's already on the
ground they've done really well